[Music]
as a cloud architect you might find
yourself designing an organization-wide
golden path for your developers one in
which they can quickly build a web app
in Google Cloud I'll show you a few ways
you can use duet AI as your partner to
understand the options
better first we'll open up duet AI chat
using the icon in the cloud console
toolbar here we'll chat with duet AI as
we would another human being in any chat
application you could also use duet AI
chat in some popular idees like vs code
with our Google Cloud
extensions we'll start telling duet AI
that we are designing a multi-tier web
app on Google cloud and that we first
want information on what to use for the
compute tier it is important to provide
as many details as we would provide a
subject matter expert so let's also make
it clear we are serving traffic over the
public internet and that we would like
fully managed
[Music]
services in just a few moments duet AI
has provided us with quite a bit of
information let's say that we are
creating the fastest path to running
smaller web apps in our organization the
description given for cloud run seems to
meet our requirements let's just confirm
this by checking which metrics Cloud run
uses for
autoscaling after a moment duet AI gives
us an answer about incoming requests and
also provides a link to follow for more
information since du aai told us that
cloud run uses the number of incoming
requests for autoscaling let's see where
those requests might come from by asking
how it is exposed to users over the
internet and the response we get back
talks about a public load balancer which
is probably fine for our applications
but some apps might need to be available
only to users with the correct
permissions let's ask how how easy it is
to only allow authenticated users access
to an
application and great it looks like
there is an easy way to accomplish that
duet aai also provides a bit of
description as to how to accomplish this
and what to expect plus more information
is available if we want to read further
finally our goal is to make this as
simple as possible for our developers we
prefer they didn't need to write any
configuration related to infrastructure
like Docker files also we've already
standardized on jeno as our web
framework let's ask duet AI if we could
deploy these types of apps without the
need to containerize
anything again duet aai responds in the
positive and provides even more context
to allow us to use it as we need it
looks like Cloud run is the way will go
for the compute layer now onto the
caching layer duet AI will use our
previous discussion and answer with that
discussion in
mind let's ask how we can introduce a
caching layer and ask to prioritize
fully manage services for this tier as
well and our response recommends Cloud
memory store Cloud CDN and
redus Cloud memory store sounds the most
reasonable but a good architect has
security
concerns let's ensure communication
between Cloud run and Cloud memory store
is
[Music]
private here is the response and there
is a step to take in ensuring private
communication a serverless vbc access
connector I'm glad we asked that
question and glad duet AI was able to
help with the caching
tier apps of any complexity deal with
storing and using data a relational
database might be the way you'd like
your developers to go continuing our
conversation with duet AI let's ask what
it recommends and let it know we'd like
to continue prioritizing fully managed
Services a few moments later the
response lets us know there are a few
options for us but given our previous
discussion tells us about cloudsql first
given our goals and developer expertise
with SQL this seems like a perfect
solution with our three tiers settled
upon how would we go about deploying an
app that uses Cloud run Cloud memory
store and cloudsql together let's ask
duet AI one more
time and of course du AI responds with a
solution that has already been developed
in a short conversation we've come up
with a multi-tiered web app architecture
that fits our needs and we can move
forward with testing it to finalize any
thoughts we have on using it duet AI is
a great tool to use when you would
normally think out loud but would also
like to get answers to those thoughts as
an architect you are likely to have many
questions when deciding on the best
Solutions and duet AI can be there for
you find out about that and more
workflows that can help with by visiting
goo.
go- A-
[Music]
overview